c'est désormais officiel le 20 novembre
prochain le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va accueillir les
meilleurs pistards de la planète à
l'occasion de la ligue des champions
piste ici une toute nouvelle compétition
répartis sur six soirées pendant six
semaines avec 72 coureurs on aura la
crème de la crème parce qu'en fait les
coureurs doivent participent au choix du
monde d'abord ils ont rendu est
qualifiée pour le championnat du monde
et aux championnats du monde
seuls les meilleurs en fait se seront
qualifiés pour aller dans cette ligue
des champions
trente six hommes 36 femmes c'est la
parité c'est super quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant avec les meilleurs
athlètes du monde
cette nouvelle compétition a également
pour objectif de booster les audiences
du cyclisme sur piste à travers le monde
on est sur un format très court 2 heures
on vient d'abord au vélodrome comme on
va venir voir une une pièce de théâtre
comme on va venir à voir un match de
foot comme on va venir voir autre chose
on va venir voir un spectacle un
spectacle avec des athlètes y aura aussi
de la musique du show mais comme ça va
être des proies m'a très très court
très compact une nouvelle formule qui a
convaincu le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le site
accueillera la deuxième manche
le but promouvoir la structure en vue
des jeux olympiques de 2024
la notoriété de la visibilité mais
également cela va permettre de l'ouvrir
à nouveau au public on va retrouver la
passion le fait que ce vélodrome sera
complet comme il a été pour les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste ya maintenant quelques années
en gros c'est le dynamisme la visibilité
pour que la fête soit encore plus
réussie le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines espèrent pouvoir
accueillir le maximum de public dans ses
gradins si la situation sanitaire le
permet en novembre